I
welcome to our panel session this is
going to be a discussion around the
challenges and frontiers of data science
in Europe so at PI data London several
months ago when we ran the first PI data
outside of the US we experimented with
running a panel at the end of the day to
begin to understand the data science
that the space around it in London and
in the UK and so here we're expanding on
that idea and looking at Europe in
general but really focused around Berlin
trying to see what the what the
challenges are what's what's what's
working right now what maybe is missing
and then try to see who is involved in
the local community to help some of you
meet each other so that we can begin to
bind the community out here and grow a
larger European data science Python
community and of course build towards
the next PI data series of conference
events on the subject of binding the
community Valentin are we going to the
pub after this supposedly so yes and
where might we be going to the pub so
the idea is to go to the hofbrauhaus
which is around the corner from here and
James went there last night so he knows
where it is and Ian went there so he
knows where in many times they wear
lederhosen it's about a four minute walk
away and you can buy liter beers which
are larger than your head and you have
to get a photograph holding the beer up
show another beer is bigger than your
head there have been many of those
photographs so I'm going to introduce
the panel very briefly and myself now
let them introduce themselves will have
a few questions for you just so we can
set the scene and then I've got some
leading questions for my panelists I
expect you to drive in with leading
questions as well preferably give them a
hard time question them in some hard way
let's finish the end of the day on an
upbeat note by beating up the panelists
with hard questions so my name is Ian
I'm one of the co-organizers of the pie
later London conference and I
home run the PI data London meet up now
which runs regularly and I think
Valentino mentioned the PI data Berlin
meter which is beginning to form out
here I'm a data scientist back in London
I've been consulting for over 10 years
almost exclusively using Python I've
just finished writing a book with no
Riley on high-performance Python please
buy it's going to be amazing and it'll
teach you load about high performance
computing and I do a lot of Python
training around data science and so
those are my areas of interest if you
want chat about this later in the pub
please come and have a chat with me here
on the panel we have we have Valentin so
the local organizer of PI data Berlin
meet up and one of the co-organizers of
this conference so on that note let's
say thank you to valentin and bikes and
by extension of course to all of the
organizers of pi data berlin and he runs
his own consultancy engineering with
python he's been a speaker at euro
python and he's a trainer for python as
well and he's particularly interested in
fast data compression and that's what
he's been talking on we have Kim so Kim
comes from the UK but isn't British
she's running the science the data
science initiative she's got a sponsor
in the conference she's gotta stand
outside looking to turn PhD graduates
into through a bootcamp to be ready for
work in industry and she's interested in
speaking to anyone who is either
interested in turning their PhD skills
into a more marketable state ready for
industry or anyone looking to hire PhDs
as data scientists we have Adam who is a
Texan living here in Berlin he is the
chief data scientist ins an ox and we'll
be taking an opinionated stance I hope
on the local data science scene and
James Powell I was going to introduce
him as our special correspondent from
the USA but due to Google's auto correct
his hour special dissident from the USA
he Co runs the Python
New York Python user group and I imagine
many of you have been introduced to him
during his talk earlier today so I'll
let you guys just briefly introduce
yourselves a couple of sentences to
build them what I've just said so over
to you valentin and so to begin with i'd
like to thank all of the people that are
involved in organizing the PI data
conference so especially Leia cilan Leia
are you in the room let's give her a big
hand so she's she's done a terrific job
coordinating everything all the way from
Austin Texas and then she flew in here
on on Wednesday morning and she came
straight to the Euro python conference
and she's just been behind the scenes
organizing things ever since then hi
Leah and then we have a couple of
volunteers so Phillip who's staffing the
video booth right now and but meet up
here who is also one of the organizers
of the local PI data meet up and
Svetlana were you in the audience
somewhere okay so so atlanta is there as
well and esri so let's give those people
a hand too
and of course James I'm so just briefly
about myself so I've been I have a
degree in neuroscience but ever since I
finished that I've been doing a lot of
data engineering work I've always been
interested in sort of how the tools work
under the hood how numpy works under the
hood how you can achieve sort of very
fast very fast computation in Python
sort of how that works at the sea level
how it works with memory allocation how
to avoid sort of temporary copies and
memory tools like no max and so on so
those are really the things that I'm
interested in alongside that I also one
of the core contributors of the Lost
compression library that Francis Galton
talked about this morning so it's
basically the the two of us more or less
that are sort of spearheading that
effort okay hello yeah I'm really
pleased to be here it looks like a great
event I've already talked to quite a
number of you and quite a mix of people
very interesting I i come from a science
background I done a PhD in astrophysics
and then I worked as a scientist for a
number of years before trying to make a
transition out of academia I found that
very difficult in the sense of knowing
what can I do what are my transferable
skills how do I apply for jobs etc
decided to do it by going through an
academic route so i did an mba in the UK
and then thinking about these problems
started and two companies pv go
recruitment and pv go academy which is
all about trying to help phd's make that
transition specifically into data
science roles and so we started the
estudias program in response to this and
we're taking 85 PhDs this year we're
starting in one week it's really
exciting and then it's a four-week
program first week lectures and
exercises for then four weeks working
with our partner companies on projects
mentored by the partner companies we've
got 22 commercial partners main one
being KPMG but also
there's like Hortonworks royal mail lots
of startups so very diverse program both
on the student side and on the company
side and just really excited to get
started on that so if you're interested
in talking to me about that i'll be here
all of tomorrow as well so stop by the
booth then thanks so as Ian mentioned
Adam from the US I've been in Berlin for
about three years currently responsible
for all of the data science and the
software engineering functions at xanax
which is one of the largest affiliate
networks in the world I think we're
probably the largest in Europe right now
we have a huge range of clients about
5,000 advertisers work with us and my
background is actually in in applied
mathematics so I've been in the tech
industry let's say since the late 90s
right now i'm working in online
marketing and advertising before I
worked in financial services and before
that oil and gas and a variety of other
industries so that's sort of the area at
which I'm looking at the at the data
science sphere hi I'm James Powell it's
nice to see so many people here today I
think this has been an awesome day so
far just to introduce myself I usually
come to these events representing NYC
Python you may or may not know of NYC
Python it is the world's largest and
most active python meetup group we have
over 5,500 members we have four events
every week and every other Thursday we
have a gigantic event about this size at
different starts in New York City it's
an amazing group the amount of
enthusiasm and energy in the US for
python is huge during the day i work in
the finance industry i'm the managing
partner of a finance analytics company
called the python quants and we build
infrastructure and analytics for hedge
funds we do a little bit of training and
we have a distributed Python quants
platform and that's all about me let's
change
I'm also from Texas I'm also from Texas
so high five on that yeah it's the
greatest country on earth ooh um so if
if Texas weren't dragged down by the
rest of the US and fielded its own
soccer team we would have beaten Germany
72 one that's all I'm saying okay so
I've got questions for the panel I first
want to set the scene by so we can learn
a bit more about you guys and so hands
up how many of you are actively working
in data science Oh on a monthly basis
you actively work in data science so
that's a good clear majority okay how
many of you work within academia in some
shape or form should professor-student
whatever okay how many of you are
researchers in industry okay yeah and
how many of you are developers in
industry ok so that's that's kind of an
interesting mix so it's a euro sci-fi a
couple of years ago it was quite clear
that the the audience was majority
academic with some researchers in
industry and very few developers so here
we've ever wanted third split so that's
a nicer split for building a community
and discussing ways to share ideas and
how many of you are not in data science
and a cross training into this idea and
so using the conference for some
research many of you some of you ok and
ok then a bunch of you to come and for
those of you working in industry how
many of you work at a company that's got
over a thousand employees ok and how
many with over a hundred employees ok
and how many how many in startups ok
that's very different to the euro CyHi
audience and how many save freelancers
are just a tiny kind of consulting
company that be me as well ok James do
want to contrast that to the pike want
meetup you had in the states where you
asked a similar question so I asked the
same
sort of questions at a conference that i
ran in march of this year called for
python quads and we asked about you know
the distribution and we saw a mix
between mostly people working in the
industry using data analytics and
finance a small set of researchers and
the rest were students i'd say that the
majority of people there worked in big
bank finance at companies like GE sha or
bloomberg or JP Morgan or bank of
america and i'm really impressed to see
so many of you working in no
up-and-coming small startups I think
that's amazing so certainly there's a
contrast to me here compared back to
London where the startup scene was
definitely represented but not to the
degree that it seems to be represented
here and I have a view from London of
the the Berlin startup scene being
interesting and growing but I didn't
expect so many hands to come up so
there's a definite emphasis difference
between London and here and I'm guessing
from other places in the US do you mind
if I piggyback one question on that how
many people here use Python every single
day how many people use other languages
like our or MATLAB how many people you
do Python as their main focus nothing
else just Python and hum and how many
people mix between the two like fifty
percent Python or maybe minority Python
okay and then one more question I was
very curious about is how many people
use Python as a kind of like a systems
language like gluing different pieces
together how many as just your pure data
analytics like you're in ipython
notebook every single day and you're
using that as a replacement for matlab
or are okay and it does anybody builds
applications in python like full-fledged
applications oh wow it's a really wild
yeah okay a little business question how
many of you are in charge of budgets so
how many of you had like developers but
how many of you are actually in charge
of a budget okay not so many of you need
some more budget holders to from the
next event okay we'll work on that one
quick survey of tools being used how
many of you use pandas okay that was
easily going to be very popular and
numpy it's probably all of us a psychic
learn okay seitan what are the famous
tool should I be asking about a psychic
image cool psychic stats know any others
to ask for the panel stat models or pi
PI tables okay matplotlib maybe yeah
methylation I'm sure that's yeah many of
us come people actually like the way map
out lip looks yeah what about ggplot oh
that's Seaborn okay does anyone use Vega
Vincent Vega that's oh wow got some
cutting-edge folks in the audience okay
so um thank you for sharing that we've
got a bit of an idea about you and how
the community is different here from
London from the US so we'll move on to
some questions for the panel so
panelists what sort of value can be
uncovered when a company switches into
using data science so pick an example of
when you've been with a company they
haven't been particularly using data
science and then they wish to extract
value from their data what kind of
success story comes out of that so so I
think one of the problems that a lot of
companies have and this is something
that that I've seen when they come come
to talk to me is they say we have all
this data we don't know what to do with
it and we want to change our company
strategy we want to be more data focused
and all this kind of stuff there are a
lot of different first steps that
that go into that usually it's some kind
of data audit where I go in and look to
see what they have and how it could be
used and if the data is even valuable
and and so I think you said what's one
of the first things it changes and one
of the first things that changes is the
mentality of the people who are running
the company about how valuable their
data is because they start out by
thinking that's just the most fantastic
thing ever and their data is a special
snowflake that's somehow more valuable
than everyone else's data and discover
it's really dirty and horrible one
inconsistent sorry and they discover its
inconsistencies and dirtiness exactly
it's so I think the first the first
thing to change hopefully is the
perception about what the data is and
how usable it is and the quality of the
data and that's that's something that's
a hard pill to swallow for a lot of
companies because they haven't been
thinking about that before they maybe
we're storing some data they didn't
realize that they weren't storing the
most important parts or they weren't
storing it in a very usable way or they
weren't designing their systems in a way
that allowed for building data products
in the future so the first thing that I
see the changes which is an unfortunate
thing to be honest is an adjustment of
expectations then that should be what
happens because a lot of times the
people who are making decisions about
making company more data focus they're
not so well versed in what that really
means so one of the first things that
changes is the mentality that people
have about their data so I work in the
finance industry and in the finance
industry kind of data science has a
different meaning i mean it's difficult
to divorce data and data analytics from
the way that people trade in the finance
industry i mean even very discretionary
hedge funds will still kind of couch
everything in some analysis of some
signal however if you look at small
funds especially on the buy side you can
see that this technology is often
extremely degenerate there's an enormous
amount of Excel there is just
uncontrollable complexity of this the
ability to do complex models is very
very limited it's pretty miserable and
one thing that really really excites me
about python is i'll give i'll give you
a
scenario that happened to me only a
couple months ago I was sitting with a
portfolio manager of a hedge fund and he
said I have this signal and I want to
change the way that we're doing this an
ounce of the signal weirdy trending it
and we were doing a DFA and we want to
do a centered moving average instead and
he sat down this is a guy who had never
programmed before in his life not even a
single line of vba he sat down with me
and we were about to look at and he said
look I already looked through the numpy
documentation and I pieced these two
pieces together I use a convolution
function and Ike involved it against a
series of ones and I think this is right
is this correct my goodness this guy had
never programmed before and he was
sitting in front of an I Python notebook
with full confidence writing code to do
his analyses and I've never seen
somebody I've never seen people take to
technology in that way excel is an
enabler in this fashion but just the
availability of data analytics to nom
programmers in the Python numpy ipython
notebook scifi pandas ecosystem is is
just absolutely amazing mm-hmm nobody
else's as encouraged as I am so we have
a mic over there that's lie you're very
welcome to go up to it neither politely
wait to ask a question or simply to
heckle or just to shout out loud so
you're very welcome to join in this
discussion if you have a point you want
to make about a company that you've
worked with or seen who has had a good
experience switching the data size this
would be a great place to share it and
certainly from my experience back in
London building on a point that Adam
just made about the data quality and
often an early discussion is about the
data they've got and the end results
they want to obtain and then having
discussed the wonderful data that they
inevitably believe that they have and
then the results they want to obtain it
turns out they don't have enough data
and it's import quality or perhaps let's
say they want to do a classification
task so they need positive and negative
training samples it turns out they've
got all of the positive samples they've
got millions of them but I've been
deleting all the negative samples and
they just know it's great we'll get some
things off the internet and they'll
become the negative baseline and of
course that'll be a rubbish staining set
training set that would really mess up
one's results and so explaining the need
for data quality becomes
to that and and so one of the
conversations I tried to have with
clients is to get involved them and
explain early on starts thinking about
your data start thinking about what it
is you want to achieve were there in six
months or 12 months time and begin to
adjust getting your data set ready so
that when you come to exploit that data
it's in a ready state you can print a
data scientist and really begin to pour
some value out of it did anyone else on
the panel have something to add to that
well i was thinking about your original
question around what a value company get
when they switch from original from sort
of classic analytics to today to science
and I was thinking through our 22
partner companies and the thing is that
we've got 15 startups with us and and
all of them are pretty much based around
data science so they haven't switched as
such so so can't talk about them and
then I thought about which ones are
established companies we've got
companies like KPMG like royal mail etc
that are just starting really so I
couldn't actually think of an example of
someone that has already switched but
what's interesting from our point of
view is how these established companies
try to swish because we've got
everything from the companies that say
okay we'll hire one person and we'll see
what they can do and then we'll move on
and maybe hire some more to other
examples like Royal Mail has really been
impressive in to us in that they've
decided today this year to hire one
really senior guy give him a budget give
him give him the right to basically
start his old apartment hire 10 people
this year that's going to work across
the whole of a royal mail which to those
of you who are British understand that's
a massive task but they've actually
given the guy the right to do that so so
that's that's actually one of the
challenges to companies is to big
companies is how do you get that started
better yeah mm-hmm
ah so which arguments panelists are
important to present to managers to
begin to make them believe in the power
of data science and the requirement to
put a budget that way well it's it's
tough I mean we can talk about our
experiences in that if you want to hire
one person then first of all you're
going to have to hire the unicorn the
one that you can't find and if you can't
find that person that person is
extremely expensive so it's going to be
a large investment that one person will
probably quit after three months because
there will be completely overwhelmed and
and not be able to shoulder that big
responsibility of showing the value of
data science and we can talk about how
you need a diverse set of skills that
work together as a team and then of
course if you can go in and you can have
a look at what data they have in a sort
of consultancy way say here is some
low-hanging fruit that you can quickly
get done quickly get some value out of
if you can prove that and at the same
time prove that you need to hire a team
to do it that tends to work I mean for
business you always have to show what is
the return on investment and if you can
show that this low hanging fruit will
within six months give you one percent
decrease in sales or whatever if you're
a big company that's that's a really big
deal yeah I I have a follow-up question
for Adam so basically do you want to go
two points on that volunteer and yeah
but I can't remember what it was so
sorry about the cannot go so basically
as Adam you mentioned that it's
difficult for established companies to
form a form and data collection
mechanism so how I take it is as data as
culture until my developers start to
understand why it is important to
collect data they would not write
applications that will emit data in the
correct format now I work with a data
platform team and we are always
preaching we should log unstructured
data we should have Jason as a format
because it's flexible but often we've
seen that the application start to abuse
that because they would just generate
random set of keys and random set of
values for example at times we've we
figured out that
even keeping a date format intact in
numerous number of applications become
the challenge and when you query for a
particular date format you don't have
that data right so basically how do we
bring data as a culture in the
developers talking about say we have a
team of 100 to 200 developers now
telling them that data is very important
because in in this world of e-commerce
websites you want your websites to
personalize basis users you want to
better recommendations and that is all
bases data unless your application start
emitting data you cannot build a build
build a layer or layer on top of that so
how do i basically figure this out and
what's this what's the trade-off between
preaching data as a culture and having a
good data science team at my dumpling
I'm sorry well you suppose different
areas called culture data is called I
mean how do we get this in the mindset
of through probably there's no sdlc
involved that says data is part of the
SDLC you should write test cases around
your data formats you should write stuff
around that and how it is being consumed
by the applications itself so example
there are there are manual pieces where
you do analytics where census data
science comes into the team and there
are pieces where you have feedback loops
very no data is automatically flowing
back to the applications and
applications are transforming themselves
spaces that data is flowing over there
so probably the point is how do I bring
data data as part of the SDLC life cycle
that we have in which developers then
play a key role too so I think there's
two things there one is how does one
develop a good data collection culture
and the other one is hell do developers
store the right kind of data so that
it's ready for analysis and I guess
behind that is the question of why would
one analyze this data in the first place
so what kind of experience have you had
around land so I think you can kind of
break it down into if you're doing a new
product or something that exists already
if it's if it's something that already
exists good luck on changing it if it's
in production and it's generating
revenue that's that's always tough the
the question you had specifically about
about date formats or something like
this and unstructured logging one thing
that I always try to advocate as a kind
of cultural thing in a company is to
make sure that any data you're pushing
around has some kind of scheme
on it because as you said you can use
JSON it's nice it's human readable it's
it's convenient but people will abuse it
and and they do so for example at xanax
we use protocol buffers to push data
around in our systems and it helps it
helps a lot that's a good first step and
in the beginning you may have to do some
explaining two engineers and say well
why do I have to put a scheme on this I
don't want to the database has a scheme
and why should I care but there there
are reasons why you would want this for
the data in transit and so you'll have
to you'll have to sell it a little bit
because if if you are starting out doing
data science at a company that never had
that before they never thought about
these problems it wasn't part of their
business requirement that the data
needed to be somehow cared for so you're
kind of going you're gonna have to sell
it a little bit that's that's the basic
answer the The Associated question was
how do you participate in the
development lifecycle how do you do this
there are a couple of ways one you can
have a data science team where the data
scientists are integrated into
development teams that's one approach
and it works really well especially for
companies that are trying to make a
cultural change the other way is to have
a team that serves as kind of internal
consultants which is slightly different
so instead of having a data scientist in
an engineering team they're available to
an engineering team and it should be the
same also for the product teams I think
that's really important especially in
companies that have product departments
they're going to be focused on a
slightly different set of metrics that
are more business focused what stuff
should I measure about the product to
demonstrate that it's valuable for the
business and in that case it really pays
to be involved in every step so even
before it goes to engineering when the
product teams are still thinking about
it and they want to build it it's really
a good idea to sit with them and help
them come up with how they plan to
measure their product and then once you
have that picture as it goes into the
engineering teams you can work with them
because you have the background from the
product side about about the product so
there have been cases where I've started
a discussion with with a product owner
or something and they've had fifty or a
ridiculously long list of things they
want to measure about the product and
really they just need one they just need
one and and I think in terms of adding
valuable things to the organization of
course schemas on data important but
there's also the way you think about
problems and if you if you're a data
focused person you're thinking about
these data problems and how to collect
it in a different way you've reduced the
complexity for the company a huge amount
if you've taken 50 metrics down to one
so for anyone who is here this morning
for jp's keynote that's a big deal and
that pays off long term thank you and I
just could like to add something so in
the past I've spoken to a couple of
people at companies mostly engineers and
I found that they weren't really aware
of what you can actually do with data
sort of you know they're aware of sort
of this big data which is I I mean I
think that's a bit of a hype sort of
this big data like buzzword and people
are like yeah Big Data this big data
that and a lot of people equate big data
with sort of NSA surveillance and and
sort of in a way I guess that's true but
there's actually like a whole lot of
like useful things that you can do with
big data and what springs to my mind is
always this example of the so Google has
this thing where they can basically what
they did was they collected keywords of
like during flu outbreaks and so they
were able to essentially using the the
search terms that were entered into
Google they were able to predict where
sort of a flu a flu outbreak was going
to happen in the US and this is sort of
when I ever this very sort of vivid
memory I explained this to sort of a
senior level engineer and he was like oh
right and he sort of had this like I
opening moment where he was like sort of
you know you could sort of see like the
the cogs ticking in his head where he
was like oh right so I can do this and
this and this and suddenly he was
starting to generate ideas you know what
he could do with like his company's data
it was just sort of he wasn't actually
aware that you can just take a whole lot
of data you know and then just basically
dumped it into a huge correlation and
then be able to predict things so
there's this book it's called big data
I can't remember who the authors are but
that's sort of one of the books it's
like a popular scientific book and you
know I would recommend to sort of
distribute this in the company just get
people sort of reading it so that they
develop an awareness of like what data
actually is why data is valuable and the
kinds of things that you can that you
can do creatively with data so that mean
one question and then we'll move on to
the next topic of this so I have sort of
I want to hear as an experience and then
follow-up cushion on that so in my
limited experience working with industry
on data science usually companies we
don't have a data science product in
place or are not using their own data
have something in production which is
more like an expert system based on some
heuristic rules or some market research
not necessarily on the data they
actually have accumulated but from some
other data on some other people have
done some research and that's what they
have adapted as their expert system yeah
so this is generating revenue sometimes
and then they want to use their own data
because they have now accumulated over
time some data which they want to
explore to see how how whatever the
heuristics they were applying before how
well are they actually mirrored in their
own data yeah so here comes the
transition when when you really want to
change an existing system which is in
production and you want to use a machine
learning-based for example data science
product which is actually supplementing
this or maybe in the long run replacing
this expert system what kind of let's
say phase or what kind of life cycle do
you think is most useful for a company
who wants to transition from a expert
based system to a more data-driven
machine learning-based or lesser data
science product based system no harm
so I think they're they're sort of two
ways this can go and when you say expert
system you can have a rules-based system
that's doing some kind of automated
processing that's one way but a lot of
times expert systems are actually some
human somewhere that looks at the
spreadsheet and make some decision and
this it's it may sound repetitive but a
lot of problems in data science aren't
so much about the tools I mean I know
we're at a technical conference that's
focused on technical stuff but a lot of
it's very much culture stuff really is
and when it comes to replacing expert
systems if it's a person that's a
challenge because they have their own
self-interests and things like this if
it's if it's a technical system that's
running somewhere depending on what kind
of architecture you have you can
implement whatever idea you have in
parallel and measure the performance
difference and if it's if it's a clear
benefit then from the business
perspective there's no reason not to use
your system assuming there's not some
massive risk or something like this
involved so I think from the technical
side it's it's not super hard if you
have if you have legacy software that
that runs and you just come up with
something better as long as you can show
that it's just a stable and it's more
effective then it shouldn't be that much
of a problem if it's about a department
that you have suddenly made unnecessary
because you built a fancy recommender
system that's a much different thing to
change and I mean it doesn't make sense
to lose all that domain knowledge either
so you can't really say that okay now I
built a machine I don't need these
people it doesn't work that way those
people still are extremely valuable and
you have to find ways for them to help
the company different from in a
different way than what they were doing
before so I think in terms of replacing
if you stick with replacing the tech
that's cool making massive cultural
changes like now this departments not
necessary that's that's a very different
thing just a brief comment on that so I
was actually talking about a technical
system not a department but that's a
valid point I agree and I also believe
that data data driven system
is needs needs that kind of less
supervision so that it is not sort of
losing the expert Oh Pete unless a the
expertise which you have actually
gathered from the domain and all that so
the human element always is there and
it's very useful i guess as suppose it
as a supervisory system or something
which keeps an eye on the automatic
system yeah so but yeah that was but a
lot of systems are not so automated I
mean it was mentioned already and in
finance I know I spent a lot of time
finance a lot of people are pushing
around Excel spreadsheets it is
ubiquitous and so in that case you have
an expert system that's yeah there's
some technology there because people
maybe have extremely fancy spreadsheets
but at the end of the day it's still a
person that's actually doing the work so
not all expert systems or not all
systems are necessarily technical I mean
in finance you can say that part of the
system for the trading is and is
captured in the gut feeling of the
trader himself right so there's an
expert system you can ever replace I
remember many many years ago I was at
Lehman Brothers looking at like a black
Harrison ski model amendments that they
had made and one of the things that we
did in this analysis was we try to we
try to we tried to match model outputs
to try to backtest it essentially and
there was one assumption that
irrespective of how the model outputs
looked the traders were using this as
one of the outputs to their gut feeling
and they had some internal intangible
unrepresentable model of how the market
worked that was driving them to make or
in the case of Lehman Brothers not make
money and this is something that's very
very hard to replace it i don't know
that you necessarily want to replace it
you just want to perhaps control it or
improve upon it or augment it in some
way and in terms of systems that are
part human part machine I've had this at
a company before yeah well that would be
kind of cool but no one thing that we
did in order to prevent this because if
you have a group of people that are used
to making decisions about something and
suddenly you come up with this awesome
machine that does a great job they're
going to fiddle with it and that's kind
of what you mentioned is that they took
the output as as
one factor in their ultimate decision
and one thing we did and you said find
ways to try to control it or influence
it is we had the machine running and it
was possible to override it but you had
to go through a certain process to do
that because in the beginning when we
released it we thought okay this is
going to be great because it works great
so no one will touch it because it works
so wonderfully and that was maybe a
little bit naive because it didn't work
out that way people started messing with
it immediately so we very soon had to
come up with a way to let the system run
to let it work to let it learn but also
have this kind of override system in
place so yeah control controlling that
is is the thing yeah okay so I'm going
to step on to the next question and this
is something that Adam and Valentin will
have an opinion on them hopefully some
of you as well and so I'm curious about
out the audience that we have attending
pie later this weekend which industries
you would expect to be here so Berliners
in particular which industries you would
expect to be at a data science
conference who aren't here so I ask this
because back in London when we had the
PI data London we noticed that although
there's a lot of farmer research in
London and in the UK there was one
representative and it was one of our
organizers from farmer so there was an
interesting hole and it turns out that
the farmer industry doesn't use pizen
they've got a lot of numbers a lot of
data but they don't use Python so there
was an interesting bridge to try and
build their into the farmer community
and that was what this co-organizer was
attempting to do and I don't think we
had any one from oil and gas in the in
the community people who are local out
here and so Adam and Valentin will start
um which industries do you think I'm
missing here that maybe should be either
brought into the community or there's
some strong reason why they're not in
the poison okay ask we should maybe ask
if is there anyone from the
pharmaceutical industry here would you
expect foam to be in Berlin I'm ignorant
here well so I saw this map the other
day of sort of large companies in
Germany and most of them are actually
sort of based in
in german it's called button button back
so it's in the south and in Munich and
sort of like all the car manufacturers
are sort of there as well I'm not really
sure what I would expect I mean I guess
and we could ask oil and gas anyone
finance web based companies so I mean
that's sort of what I would expect I
would expect a lot of people from web
companies to be here and that seems to
be accurate is there anyone from sort of
heavy industry manufacturing although we
had andreas Ouisa is there anyone from
the car industry vehicle car industry
what about alternative power okay like
microchips hardware consulting like
operations management chef in the blue
t-shirt
and as I know and I need my son and
mother because that's what is bottom the
aircraft and they have given extremely
low margin and one went to the to the
groceries and your mother and and they
did in guam valentine's one-year i'm a
modified height-loving first Javier was
in the wrong musical I had to get 11 my
nose because the starting point where am
i crying is that you are you sure who's
your windows and they never oneself haha
everything is done thank you I love
sorry fennekin some high end if you are
a student there all dangers and things
in committing evil amazing with the
uterus fear and pain and then you go
development ministry and they your
unease and everybody knows you have a
view on Travis mother is to be quite the
trials so n then the story is ends fine
so did you guys get it done
continued mexicana the most part except
what we can serve everything there and
if you get into the universe into them
maybe something they are the guys in
development department of car companies
are I'm not and then somehow they budget
detective conferences and then your
promises okay and so on that point and
how many people when they use Python on
a new machine do a fresh install by
downloading Python something I used to
do but I haven't done for a number of
years does anyone make a native fresh
install you compile from source of
course James compulsion source how many
people use the influence distribution to
either the old EPD or the newer canopy
just one two three okay how many people
use anaconda it's probably going to be
the bigger winner any other deposits why
system packages linux system packages
any other main distributions that i
forgot homebrew okay home bro on a mac
homebrew a couple of okay I thought
don't ever install rope or something
like that it just provides report okay
okay so Anna cazzo for those of you who
don't know the Anaconda distribution
it's worth noting that it is very matlab
like it's not a clone of matlab but it
does come with all the packages my
matlab matlab colleague was so relieved
when he discovered the spider ID inside
anaconda because it looks just like the
matlab environment and then he was
quickly up and running with an
interactive you're on the namespace and
the like so yeah it's maybe worth
exploring there's a question
our good good and potentially
contentious question so in a talk a few
days ago at one of the pipe I talks pie
pie pie the just-in-time compiler Roman
had a the contentious 2.8 t-shirt on
which I personally quite disagree with
I've just made the switch to python 3 so
let's ask the question how many of you
are using Python 2.7 in your daily life
okay it's almost all of us and how many
are how many have switched to only use
Python 3 okay and how many use a mix of
Python 2 and 3 at the moment okay
personally i'll make the plug but i
think in the world of science it's about
time that we made the shift because most
of the libraries have imported for over
a year and so we can probably trust that
they are all bug free so that source of
potential error has gone away and by
switching it means we haven't got to
support two major versions just one
major version the community community
gets to move forward faster so i would
gently urge you to consider the switch
certainly for new projects and python 3
is a clean a language share than Python
2 does the panel have any points to add
to that you give you the microphone so
you can talk about Python 1.5 come on no
way yeah no don't give him the mind is
completely agreeing with with witty and
said I mean I I have no stake in the
matter really I haven't been in the
Python community for like 10 years so
for me it's it's one tool in a box with
many other tools and I'm often confused
about the strong support for Python 2 in
the community I don't I don't really
know why it's that way Ian and I were
discussing it a while ago so everything
we do at xanax is Python 3 when whenever
we're using Python and again I would I
would echo witty and said any any new
stuff it makes sense to do in Python 3
just an additional question how many of
you using pipe I in in production on
research but using pipe on a daily basis
anyone Oh Jason Jason one I'm Python
okay so it's all pretty much C Python
okay all right we're in the last five
minutes so I've got Oh was there a
question sorry sorry Thomas gone you've
been standing there forever I thought
one was supposed to ask one so i was
just wondering what your views on the
difference in data science industry
between states and europe on sort of
both sides one is just the providers so
startups that are developing data sense
products but also the customers in terms
of companies that want to have data
scientists and and use it and assuming
what my impression is that it's much
smaller what other where's the gap the
biggest and what can we do sada to close
those so its differences between us and
europe this is the question in data
science and what are the differences how
can we close the gap yeah yes so i think
the the biggest difference and this is
one of the things I was going to mention
is that it's simply time so I think this
is perhaps something we've also seen
historically is that the Europe is sort
of a bit behind sort of the trends that
they're happening in the States and I
think it's just a matter of time until
until we catch up and perhaps eventually
we'll have a will have an active high
data meet up here in Berlin as well I'm
not sure we can rival the number of
members that Python NYC has but i think
it's just it's just a matter of time for
sort of you know things to arrive here
to be for people to sort of become aware
of this and I think that sort of this
conference is the first step in the
right direction yeah totally I mean it's
a number of years and but I guess what
I'd like to add is that you can't bun
Europe together unfortunately it's
there's big difference between countries
in Europe UK which is what I the market
that I know most about is I would say is
ahead of the rest of Europe probably by
at least a year in time very active data
science seen loads of startups loads of
meetups
going on huge interest and companies
really really starting getting properly
started with this I think my experience
from Germany not having worked here but
having lived here for six years is that
Germans are a lot more scared of privacy
issues for instance Brits don't care
they've got CCTV anyway I mean they're
used to being spied on all the time
Germans are completely opposite as far
as I know you know there are very
private people and the whole NSA thing
that you mentioned you know big data
here is equated with an essay and being
spied on so it's negative thing and
that's why I think it might take longer
to get a whole foothold here southern
Europe is still struggling with
financial recovery so that might take
even longer so you can't really just say
Europe as a whole but but there are
differences here but yeah I think it's a
matter of time as well as you say I
think it's worth noting on there that
certainly I see in London that the data
science scene with Python started to
grow up about three years ago five years
ago I tried to organize a meetup around
around beta in London and I had almost
no response from any of the developers
that I knew and then a couple of years
later it a step here on the radar and
I've been running my consultancy for 10
years so I watch this drought turn and
grow up at the same time we've had the
euro Syfy group which has been running
for his mic in the room at mikes on the
roof I think it's for four or five years
old 66 years old so running running in
Paris and Brussels Leipzig okay so
running around Europe and running this
year in the UK so we've had a scientific
Python community it's been small to be
more academic focus than its growing up
now in parallel we have the PI data
community which is a bit more business
focused so we have two communities
running alongside alongside the growing
of Euro Python and more regional pison
user groups icon SC just recently pike
on Ireland in a couple of months time
and so we're seeing the community
growing up very quickly and so I think
it is Lackey behind the states but at
the same time I think it is growing
quickly and becoming really quite rich
and interesting place and now we're in
the last
i'm going to call in a in a minute or so
so i'm just going to ask i'm curious
about the skills that are missing in
companies which would which hinder the
greater adoption of python and data
signs and so there's a quick survey of
hands and how many of your of the
companies or institutions that you're in
would pay to send people on a course for
basic python just learning python from
the get-go okay and how many it will pay
and have a demand for doing that okay
and how many would do that for for
numeric school so say a numpy course a
numpy courts to start to understand
America Python so do you mind yeah and
then what about things like machine
learning so scikit-learn and other
machine learning tools how many might
build on top of that okay a couple okay
so a pretty thin need what are the needs
are there okay pandas and as the data
manipulation data engineering maybe less
or maybe it's very well documented
already and what other are there so
let's close off for this question are
there any other skills that are missing
in the community that are missing in
academia and in the industrial world
which could be provided if the community
realize that there was a gap out of a
professional training or for more events
like this or more training at
conferences are there any things that we
need to be aware of in the community
that we can begin to provide to help
grow the local seems anyone want to fire
any ideas in the sharpener oh I usually
actually a little bit people & get get
the message out there of eternia big
money southern Germany we have
of companies but they're also like a lot
of agencies and they all I have my my
perspective it's like maybe like 10 20
people working here and they sold
anything like them everything so they
don't know so it's their demand for
community driven events okay okay so you
started the mongodb meet up Valentina's
co organizing with with back meet i
think the the PI data berlin meet up and
we've seen rapid growth in the PI data
London meet up where 10 weeks old and
weighs 370 members and more members
growing and we're barely promoting it at
the moment just because we're already
over capacity and there was another hand
that went up with an idea right now
quiet place i'm using I bike a girl but
very much good young
scale too many surveys cluster computing
my point of view move on these days for
research organization okay so so
improvements in the cluster compute
space both okay by my high performance
python book we discuss some cluster
computing in there including large-scale
systems as deployed by bit ly and but
it's not a research environment sure
sure ok ok ok check out if you checked
out disco and have you checked out
Olivier because there's talks that he
does about star cluster on on amazon ok
so you need your own hardware ok so more
more more tooling and help around clasp
are heaps pi spark sorry valentin ones
Nobel Prize Berg so I recently learned
that Continuum's blaze has a back end
for a pie spark and for spark which is
sort of this in memory thing built
around Hadoop um so much more
are you guys using like MPI and stuff
like that on your cluster how do you how
do you use it right now okay because
that's also not fun let's carry this on
in the inner pub afterwards so I've got
a question then James he's got a
question and if in Germany there were
more PI data Berlin whatever meetups how
many of you would attend okay so there's
a healthy demand there for some me time
so that's good to see and over to James
so I want to ask one last question of
everyone the audience and I'm going to
give you three choices and be careful
how you respond the first question is
who here in the audience is tired of
Python they're just like okay whatever
okay who here in the audience feels
python is their go-to tool it's nothing
special it's okay it gets the job done
it's something that I reach for when I
need to solve a problem and who here in
the audience is excited about Python
enthusiastic up until 3am every night
you've been doing it for 10 years and
you're still learning things new you
can't even sleep sometimes you come to a
conference like this and you learn 10
things and it's just blowing your mind
for the last 10 years you cannot you
cannot you just not it's been it's you
can't even put it into words hmm I want
to see every hand out because i think
that's that's it had a community we want
to build here and you on the panel to
don't want panelists all right we're
getting off to the pub now and Valentin
which pub we're going to so we can go to
any popular bike but the hofbrauhaus was
suggested so actually there's a curious
thing about Berliners and they only
really know that the area of Berlin that
they actually live in their own kids so
that I don't actually know where the
hofbrauhaus is but it's supposedly it's
quite close to here we will all walk out
there on mass in the next few minutes
and head there it's got a great big
football slogan across the entire
building opposite so if you want hmm a
football person giant great football
thing and opposite is a pop that seats
1,000 people and they were later hosen
so
you can't really miss it we'll be there
in a few minutes time all right thank
you very much